hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this is ai
simplified where we learn to make our
data
useful we're helping an imaginary
company that is in the process
of building their machine learning
workflow and to accelerate ai innovation
they are looking at vertex ai which
provides tools
for every step of the machine learning
workflow for managing data sets to
different ways
of training the model evaluating
deploying and making predictions
in the previous episode we started by
looking at the first part
of any ml project the data sets vertex
ai supports managed data sets for
image tabular text and video data
in this episode let's move further in
the ml workflow and
talk about building and training the
models the managed data sets we created
earlier feed directly into the model
building
and training although you can bring
external data sets
while building the model manage data
sets bring some added benefits
as i laid out in the previous episode we
have two options to train the model we
can use
automl which allows us to create high
quality
custom models with minimal effort and
machine learning expertise
and the second option is to write custom
model training code
where you can run custom training
applications in the cloud
using pre-built containers of your own
now
when should you write your own model
code and then
should you choose automl it depends so
let's see
if your use case fits a supported automl
offering then starting with automl is a
great choice
and these use cases include cases where
you have images or video classification
or object detection
text classification entity extraction
from the text
sentiment analysis of text tabular
regression and classification
but if it does not fit any of those
categories
or your model takes a mixed input type
such as you have images and then the
metadata is in the form of text
then it makes sense to use custom model
the
other technical factor could be that you
have specific requirements for the
underlying model
if you need control over your model's
architecture
framework or the exported model assets
for example maybe your model needs to be
built in tensorflow
or pi torch then you use custom model
otherwise for the basic use cases just
use auto ml
the next factor could be how experienced
is your team
with ml and ai if you have a team with
limited machine learning expertise in
building custom models
then exploring auto ml makes sense
before
looking into the custom model code
because it is the lowest barrier to
entering
another deciding factor could be your
team size
now if you have a small data science
team
and less machine learning expertise in
that team
it perhaps makes more sense to work with
automl because
custom model code would require more
time
and maintenance and use automl if you
want to develop
a quick initial model to be used as
a baseline or a proof of concept which
could eventually end up being your
production model
but if you're looking to improve on your
existing baseline or heuristics
then you might want to write your own
custom model
to test out the possibilities hopefully
these factors
have clarified which path to take when
it comes to building the models
now let's see how to build and train the
auto ml model
using vertex ai with that on to the
google cloud console
we learned how to create data sets in
the previous episode but for the sake of
completeness let's create a data set
in this example we are using credit card
fraud detection data set
available on bigquery public datasets to
create
a credit card fraud detection model i
have included the link to this dataset
below if you would like to follow along
once the data is uploaded we can analyze
our data in the rows
and columns right from the data set
details page
we can select train new model
define our objective which is
classification here
since we are labeling examples as either
fraudulent or non-fraudulent
this is where you decide whether you
want to use automl
or custom training in this video we are
focusing on automl so we will select
that stay tuned for the next episode
where i will cover custom model
next we give our model a name under the
target column
we select class this is an integer
indicating
whether or not a particular transaction
was fraudulent
zero for non-fraud and one for fraud
in the advanced options you can specify
a specific
train test split if you don't want
vertex ai to handle that automatically
for you
in this case we're using the random
assignment but you can also specify
this manually when you upload a csv of
your data
or you can have the data split
chronologically
if it has a time column in the choose
training options section
we will go to the advanced option and
since this data is heavily imbalanced
less than one percent of the data here
contains fraudulent transactions
we will choose the auc prc option
which will maximize precision recall for
the less common class
in this case we care more about ensuring
our model can classify fraudulent
transactions correctly
now the last step is compute and pricing
here we enter
one as the number of compute hours for
our budget and leave
early stopping enabled training your
automl model
for one compute hour is typically a good
start for understanding whether there is
a relationship between the features
and labels you're selected from there
you can modify
your features and train for more time to
improve
model performance then we're ready to
start training
from here we can leave the ui and we'll
get an email when our training job
completes
alright so our model is ready let's
explore the model evaluation metrics
we head to our model tab and evaluate
the model we just trained
there are many evaluation metrics here
we will focus on two the confusion
matrix and
feature importance a confusion matrix
tells us the percentage of
examples from each class in our test set
that our model predicted correctly in
the case of an imbalanced data set like
the one we're dealing with here
this is a better measure of our model's
performance than
overall accuracy remember that less than
one percent of the examples in our data
set were fraudulent transactions so
if our model accuracy is 99 there is a
good chance that it's just randomly
guessing the non-fraudulent class
99 of the time that's why looking at our
model's accuracy
for each class is a better metric here
the confusion matrix shows that our
initial model
is able to classify 85 percent of the
fraudulent examples in our test set
correctly
this is pretty good especially
considering our significant
data set imbalance next we could try
training
our model for more compute hours or
gathering
more training data to see if we can
improve that from this 85 percent
now this shows us the features that
provided the biggest signal to our model
when making predictions the feature
importance is
one type of explainable ai a field that
includes various methods for getting
more insight into how an ml model is
making predictions
the feature importance chart is
calculated as
an aggregate by looking at all of our
models predictions on our test set it
shows
us the most important features across a
batch of examples
this chart would be more exciting if
most of the features in our data set
were not obscured we might learn for
example that the type of transaction
transfer deposit etc can be the biggest
indicators of fraud
in a real world scenario these feature
importance values could be used to help
us
improve our model and to have more
confidence in its prediction
we might decide to remove the least
important features
next time we train a model or to combine
two
of our more significant features into a
feature cross
to see if this improves our model's
performance
we are looking at feature importance
across a batch here but we can also get
feature importance for
individual predictions in vertex ai and
we'll see how to do that
once we've deployed our model now that
we have trained model
the next step is to create an endpoint
in vertex ai a model resource in vertex
ai can have multiple endpoints
associated with it
and you can split traffic between
endpoints
on our model page there is deploy and
test tab
there we click deploy to endpoint give
your endpoint a name
like fraud version one or two and then
leave the traffic splitting settings as
is and then select a machine type for
your model deployment
we used an n1 high cpu2 here but you can
choose whichever machine type you would
like including one with gpus
then select done and click continue
leave the selected location settings as
is
and then click deploy your endpoint will
take a few minutes to deploy
when it is completed you will see a
green check mark next to it just like my
version one here
now we are ready to get predictions on
our deployed model
there are a few options for getting
model predictions
the ui and the api let's check out both
one by one
on your model page where your endpoint
is shown
scroll down to the test your models
section here
vertex ai has chosen random values for
each of our models features that we can
use to get a test
prediction you're welcome to change
these values if you would like
and then scroll down to the bottom of
the page and select
predict in the prediction results
section
you should see your model's predicted
percentage for
each class a confidence score of 0.99
for class 0 for example means that our
model
thinks this example is 99 non-fraudulent
the ui is a great way to make sure the
deployed endpoint
is working as expected but chances are
that you will want to get prediction
dynamically
via a rest api call to show you how to
get
model predictions here let's set up a
notebook
for that we navigate to notebooks option
and select
tensorflow without gpus once created
open the notebook instance
and then we open python3 notebook from
the launcher
in the notebook we run the command in a
cell
to install the vertex ai sdk and below
that
we add and run a new cell and the
example from our test set
next we need to create the endpoint
object
and then change the endpoint id and
project number to your specific
endpoint you can get the endpoint from
the url
and the project id from the project
dashboard
we use that to make a prediction request
to our endpoint
and we see our prediction around 0.99
for the zero class which means the model
thinks there is a 99
chance this transaction is
non-fraudulent
with that we've learned about the two
options to train our models in vertex ai
auto ml and custom training and when to
use which one
then we went into the console and
trained an automl model from scratch
in the next episode of ai simplified we
will look at
building and training a custom model in
the meantime
let's continue our discussion in the
comments below and don't forget to like
and subscribe to catch that next episode